good morning believe nation today's
message is don't pressure yourself over
to you Derek Jeter I wake up every mood
distress little TV go just try not to
put too much pressure on yourself I
think the more pressure you put on
yourself the quicker things get I think
you just try to be calm it doesn't mean
you're going to be successful I've
failed a lot more times than I've
succeeded but I'm not afraid to be in
those situations so entrepreneurs are
some of the most stressed out most
pressured people that I've ever met and
you know you're out there trying to
chase your dreams trying to accomplish
your goals you put a lot of pressure on
yourself to make that happen and I know
there's a lot of external pressures on
you two you've got your family you've
got your friends you've got society
you've got the little man who told you
you couldn't do it all these external
pressure sources on you to make it
happen and to some extent a little bit
of pressure is good right if you have
zero pressure then you're likely to be
lazy and lethargic and there's nothing
holding your feet to the fire something
to kick you into that extra gear you
have to raise the stakes enough so that
you want to go out and do work but too
much pressure as well is a bad thing too
much pressure will cause you to break
down too much pressure will cause you
massive amounts of stress too much
pressure will make your business
software will make the quality of your
product or service suffer and I know
what you're thinking say well that's
easy for you to say Evan you know I've
got bills to pay I've got mouths to feed
I've got to make some money so that I
can keep my business going and I get
that and that might mean that you take
on a part-time job just to keep your
dreams going that might mean that you
slow down on your goals on your dreams
because you realize that this is a
marathon and it's not a sprint and if
you continue putting massive amounts of
pressure on yourself then you're going
to run yourself into the gray because it
has an impact not just on your business
being able to be successful but it'll
cascade to every area of your life
and you'll start to feel it in your
health so the feel in your relationships
when you are too stressed out good stuff
does not happen so ease up a little bit
on the pressure and let things unfold
believe my question today for you guys
today is do you put too much pressure on
yourself and I'd love to hear a little
bit of story of either how you're doing
it or you're not doing it enough leave
it in the comments below I'm gonna join
in the discussion thank you guys so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and i'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of vinspresso TV I work every morning
espresso keep me going